[Musique]
il est alors à 22h50
hélas il n'est qu'à leur à 12h45 quoi
j'ai eu le temps de fuir une partie
menée quoi lutter sa dépouille
l'acquéreur tout rendez vous demain 9h
heure et une demi-heure de route sa
classe une demi heure pour déjeuner et
habille et avait en admettant tutelle
directe au second je me le direct du
genre tu vas te lever direct tu vas pas
attendre non c'est moi qui le suis je me
dis toi pas moins dix noms ok
tu t'en
aller vérifier moi je sais que tu as
envie de me regarder en plus il est 1h
du mat
ou 2h ou 4h ou peut-être 3h44
aller si ça se trouve il tresse plein de
temps à dormir
et non il dresse qu'une heure et là tu
vois pas arrêter d'y penser mon pote
avec toi n'avait toi oui toi on ne me
dit samuel tu penses maintenant on avait
dix huit heures pour
les toits avec toi réveille toi
avec toi quand tu as encore
avec toi
merde ah bah ouais mais je t'avais
prévenu
alors il va à 20h et le canal à 19h30
[Musique]
maintenant le thunder l'a dit d'ailleurs
32 quoi c'est beaucoup quoi talât et
eroglu à me suspecter tuer ça parce que
je suis un réveil c'est ça non
dans ses choix m'a regardée
et encore 2 minutes et tuba ton corps
ouais non par contre me regarde pas
parce que là j'ai l'impression que c'est
moi qui est excité c'est chelou
ouais je dis non
[Musique]
c'est qui ça
non mais j'y arriverai jamais comme ça
[Musique]